[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i saw this story it was a couple of
weeks ago we had johnny bench on the
best catcher in history two-time world
series champ
and uh johnny was going to auction off a
lot of his items and i think
what we think and when i was growing up
i thought johnny bench and pete rose and
joe morgan and tony perez they must be
as rich as anybody in the country
because they played for the big red
machine and they won world series
titles and and then you realize what
they got paid
when they were playing is a whole lot
different than what these athletes are
getting paid now and
you know i was a little bit sad that
johnny had to you know auction off his
items you're talking about
mvp won the mvp a couple of times there
are other things that gold gloves in
there
and i saw the story todd goes hey
johnny's going to keep all of his
memorabilia and i go
wait he's not going to auction it he
goes no somebody bought
all of it and gave it back to him i said
well we gotta have johnny on because
talk about a financial angel there and
uh johnny bench
joining us on the program when did you
hear about it what was your reaction
when you got
you know most of your memorabilia back
the auction was on saturday and then on
monday david hunt from hunt auctions uh
called me and said it was a great
auction and everything else and said are
you sitting down i said yeah
he said well there's a there's a guy
that
does wants to be remain anonymous
and uh he said but uh he bought 35 of
your items
and he wants to give them back to you
well
i mean i i lost it i i absolutely lost
it
i was tears rolling down and and
you know i mean it's breathtaking and to
think that you know somebody thought of
you enough i mean you couldn't believe
that that would happen
and he said the only only thing he told
me to tell you was
it was from a white-haired old jew
so i only know one white-haired old you
all you have to do is google
76ers sixth man i met this guy when i
was 19.
he was 23 we were in puerto rico we
became friends
it was just you know and every time i
went to philadelphia
we went out we had it he he never had
kids he had
rolls-royce we drove around and uh he
would come to spring training every year
and we were just great friends and he
was a real estate business in in
philadelphia
and so i text i said i'm looking for a
white-eared old jew
and i said you know and after i've wiped
all the tears away and i'm trying to
compose myself to even think that
this would even happen i i just can't
think enough and if i'm barking up the
wrong jew let me know
and he texts back and said no you got
the right view and
and he said look i can afford it and he
had texted me about five days before
that and it said
why are you doing it and this is alan
horowitz this is alan horton
alan horowitz yes and i said i'm doing
it for the kids
i said you know i've seen too many
families torn apart whether it be with
uh
memorabilia from a celebrity or an
athlete to
people who have picked paintings and
antique furniture that
do it and i wanted to make sure that my
kids were secure and
you know i just turned 73 so you know
and and all these things that are
happening to our people around us i
it was the right decision and now um
it's pretty well it's incredible dan i
mean it's just unfathomable this could
happen
how much did he spend for those 35 items
over a million dollars oh man and so
with that i started designating the
baseball hall of fame i called jane
clark
uh the chairman i said this is what's
happening
and uh what items do you want and then
the reds hall of fame and then oklahoma
sports hall of fame
and it was like i mean these people were
over the top they're saying you know the
guy
mike james in oklahoma said you know the
first thing they ask is where's johnny's
exhibit and
now we're able to put gold gloves and
we're able to put
items in there mvp trophies or whatever
that they wanted
and a couple and several will go to
binger
but you know it was interesting the kids
said dad now everybody will be able to
see
yeah it's true and he said i don't i
didn't want these in the hands of
collectors that would people would never
your fans your family would never be
able to see them and uh i had
i would have sent one to you but your
desk is totally full
i would have gotten rid of a danette i
would have gotten rid of todd
and put maybe your gold glove over there
in instead of him
absolutely so i would have made a great
four shot yeah um
how do you explain to your kids what
happened
oh i've tried i've tried and they say
really i mean they're
they can't really get their their gran
their heads around it i i called my
attorney first
and i said this is what happened he just
sat there he was stunned and then he
called me back 10 minutes later and said
are you
i still can't believe this he said and
then he's called me back the next day
and and the people that have you know
have heard about it and now the response
is just
you know alan horowitz is the angel you
know i believe there are angels among us
i mean it's the alabama song
and i don't know that dan can you ever
imagine
someone actually this actually happening
and it's still
you know we talked yesterday and uh the
only thing he wants is to meet the kids
and i'll take him to philadelphia as
soon as the
as soon as the covet clears and and we
can get up there and meet this great man
didn't you do enough damage to the
phillies where
they shouldn't be helping you
well he was more of a 76ers fan he i
made him a reds fan
it wasn't so much the damage yeah yeah
you know i did like philadelphia though
very very good to me yes i was bringing
this up
the other day that it seems like the
life expectancy of a stadium is around
30 years like riverfront three rivers
the vet they all look like big ashtrays
there i'm wondering johnny if if fenway
was built 30 years ago or wrigley built
30 years ago would they still be
standing because it feels like
we we move on like we have to have a new
one yeah
right yeah oh absolutely i don't think
there's any question that wrigley and
and fenway would be uh you know totally
redundant if you put a martin
modern ballpark out there then they got
to change dimensions and you know it
becomes just a cult thing for
for these people i mean you can see the
way they they sell out every year
every game in boston help wrigley fans
want to be out there how they're
building
the scoreboards and how how do you
change something
and you lose the aura of what these
really are it's a mystique about them
that makes everybody across the country
where do you want to go well i want to
go to wrigley field
you know i think that's the one thing
and i think they they feel like in
wrigley fields you can get into a game
you can actually do that and
boston you know it's pretty much season
tickets
and uh but it's still a standard best
ballpark though you ever played in
oh wow um i think the first time going
into dodgers
stadium i never liked to play there
because they always had great pitching
but it was like a
you know you could you know you couldn't
stand at second base made a fun go out
of there so
and and the first time i walked into the
astrodome
and our manager had a meeting before the
game says all right
get out there now look at all the stuff
in the stadium get it over with so you
can focus on
the game and you know they had those
cowboys riding across there and stars
shooting and fireworks and
and uh you know you went by the ballpark
where you were most comfortable
you know shea stadium had all the trash
and all the airplanes flying over
you got to san francisco and you know
and stu miller blew off the mound and
you know
i will pantyhose one night just to try
to keep warm and you know
and the wind's blowing across and i
would i would throw it towards shortstop
i would throw it towards shortstop so it
would blow towards second base wait wait
go back to the pantyhose here
somebody and uh we were trying to look
for long johns and
and you know they were so thick at the
time and either i don't think i
don't want to blame namath or anything
else for doing that but somebody said
that you could actually wear pantyhose
and it would it would keep you warmer
and it was cold
out there and uh no
i couldn't buy anything it didn't run
and i hate to run in a stocking
you know that's the worst thing so i i
did away with those
they only made san francisco could i now
if that's up for auction i'll bid on
your pantyhose
uh okay i won't go there dan
i i i'm sure your wife would love you
running around the rack these are
johnny's pantyhose look at these honey
yes
yeah and i paid good money for them
[Laughter]
were you i i'm gonna guess you were
there didn't stargel hit one of the
longest home runs ever at riverfront
that was it upper deck were they wait
way upper deck did they change the like
one of the seats out
to mark how far star joel hit it in in a
riverfront
i believe it was and i'll they've did
that they've done that in a couple of
states where bernie cardbo hit one off
of nolan ryan one night in the astrodome
that went way up in the upper
you know and they they started putting
targets on it and then the guys started
the the pitchers would get upset their
name was
on the list of giving up the long one
but but starjo hit one of the longest
home
runs well you might have been there i
i might have but i just remember it kept
going
and i lost track because normally you
you would look in in the green seats at
riverfront
and it just kept going and i'd lost
track of it i thought he hit it out of
the stadium
i know i know i mean that was that was
the thing where
the upper deck was uh nowhere no man's
land i mean dave concepcion only hit one
in the upper deck and left field
and i i went off the facing off of john
manafucka one time
and that was my my claim to fame but i
never got one in the upper deck but
willie's must have gone 15 or 20 rows up
i mean it was just
and and i can still he crossed home
plate and just looked at me and shrugged
shoulders he just struck me so he was
such a great guy
and he'd whip that bat around and he'd
roll that bat around and then
but he was the nicest guy but he just
sort of shrugged his shoulders i'd look
at him
when he came across home plate i mean
i've been there for some good ones
did you ever pull a crash davis and tell
the batter what was coming
no no no
no i remember when clay dalrymple was
the catcher for the
phillies and uh jean mark
told clay to tell pete what was coming
because they couldn't get him out
and said clay said told pete said look
gene wants me to tell you what's coming
and so he said okay first pit here's a
fastball right down the middle strike
one
all right here comes a curveball strike
two and pizza is standing there looking
at it and everything else and he stepped
out of the box and told them
would you tell me i don't want to know
what's coming
one night one night we were in montreal
and uh gary carter was the catcher dan
schatzeder was the pitcher
and he and it was a perfect count for a
2-1
slider on the outside and i looked back
at the kid and i said kid watch this one
he threw me the slider
wait you you knew what he was going to
do he was setting you up and you
you were yeah it was just a situation
where i knew it was that was his
favorite pitch
he was going to try that slider on the
outside and break it over and i said
what's this one kid
well i'm happy for you you got to uh
everybody shares in this everybody
benefits and they get to see that
memorabilia
and once again great thumbs up thanks to
alan horowitz it is hanukkah so you know
he uh he came to the rescue and gave you
uh a wonderful gift there and
uh oh you know i want to go i want to
cry now but
merry christmas to all of you and the
danettes and and i hope you're well i
hope your health is good thank you buddy
that's uh the great johnny bench
baseball hall of famer